foreign
fighters let's dive in Dylan danis took
a shot at Patty pimlet on Twitter during
the UFC London card on Saturday Dennis
who last fought at Bellator 222 in June
2019 tweeted that he was less than
impressed with pinlet's performance
Patty is actually terrible I expected
more from him I'd finish him in under a
minute
Twitter was quick to point out that
while danis hasn't fought in over three
years pimlet's first fight in the UFC
was only 10 months ago and he has
already amassed a 3-0 record but it
wasn't just fans on Twitter who went
after Dennis on the weighing in podcast
Josh Thompson and Big John McCarthy
blasted dannis for the Tweet he signed a
Bellator and I hope they I hope they
just let him go because he doesn't fight
there's no reason to even have him on a
contract why his last fight was in 2019
against Max Murphy excuse me Max
Humphrey all right you haven't fought
anybody you don't fight you all you do
is call people out you you do these
things on social media
Dylan either you're a fighter or you're
a keyboard Warrior
I'm just being honest if that's
2019 your last fight you're becoming the
keyboard Warrior
in the in the meantime he's out at the
clubs getting choked out by bouncers
yeah hold on dude yeah if you're not
fine how old you say you're gonna finish
Patty pill in under a minute how long
will it take the bouncer the bouncer to
[ __ ] finish here
nah it's like yeah I I feel like as soon
as that happened
we should belter should have been
offering that bouncer contract I like
that you're out of here buddy in Michael
Chandler's guest fighter press
conference at UFC London he defended
Patty and had some Choice words for
those who hate on him he's great Patty
and I have been in contact a little bit
he's a guy who's in that perfect
position where I'm the guy I'm gonna be
the champion here in the next 12 months
he is going to be nipping at my heels
coming into the top 15 coming into the
top 10 but I don't have the scarcity of
mindset when it comes to other guys in
my division especially when I see guys
who are doing it the right way in my
opinion he's a marketable guy he's a
happy guy he's the fun guy he's fun to
watch fun on the microphone he's the
total package people can hate on him all
they want but they're just being haters
because Patty pinlets the total package
can he put it all together inside the
octagon and continue to keep winning
we'll see Anthony Smith hopped on MMA
junkie radio to speak about his opponent
magamev on Clive ahead of their Clash at
UFC 277. Smith who is the betting
Underdog spoke about trying to find the
balance between not putting on Goliath
on a pedestal while also not
underestimating him I'm getting used to
just kind of being counted out there's
no disrespect for ankalaya I've got a
lot of respect for his game I really do
he's a good man he's very very good but
he's not the boogeyman that everyone is
making him out to be he's not that guy
if I don't go in there and do what I'm
supposed to do and cross my T's and Dot
my eyes it's going to be a long night
for me but he's not at least in my
opinion he's not the boogeyman that
everyone's making him out to be Smith
continued by breaking down some
ankalia's tactics that he has picked up
from film he's a normal guy he's very
simple in his game and his approach
there's no tricky [ __ ] going on there
he's never out of position he likes to
fight inside of his box he likes to walk
people down he's got a really heavy and
active lead side he's got a nice high
kick from the rear side he wants to
funnel you to the two it's the same [ __ ]
that a lot of people do his approach and
he's very smart he doesn't leave a lot
of opportunities to make mistakes but
that's my job that's my job to go in
there and make people look bad those
watching Anthony Smith and magamed on
Clive can expect a familiar Trio in the
commentary Booth mmafighting.com
reported that multiple sources have
confirmed with them that the UFC 277
commentary team will be John anik Joe
Rogan and Daniel Cormier just days after
Michael Chandler hinted at a potential
fight with Dustin Poirier ESPN's Brett
okamoto brought more clarity to the
situation after speaking with poirier's
representation in a tweet akimoto said
ask Dustin poirier's representative Tiki
gone for an update looks like it's going
to be Michael Chandler sounds like he
wants to smoke and Dustin is going to
give it to him UFC hasn't reached out
yet though
season six of Dana White's Contender
series kicked off Tuesday night with
four scheduled bouts in the featured
fight of the night Joe pifer provided
the only finish of the night and
received the only contract of the night
when he knocked out Aussie Diaz in the
second round after the event white
expressed his disappointment with the
rest of the fights and sent a message to
next week's competitors let me reiterate
what this show is about there's a lot of
talented people out there a lot of
talented Fighters a lot of talented kids
I don't watch anything on anybody before
they come here tonight you had somebody
from Faber's Camp somebody from Sarah
Longo you got all these famous teams I
don't care what you did in your career
the last five years what are you going
to do tonight so next week when you roll
in here the next crew on Tuesday show me
who you are Tuesday night that's the
only thing I'm concerned with if you
want to get into the UFC and this is
where you want to be act like Joe pifer
be Joe pifer be excited to be here be
fired up to fight try to finish the
fight try to win be Joe pifer and you
will get into the UFC white continued by
emphasizing the opportunity the show is
providing these Fighters every night is
not going to be your night but Tuesday
night [ __ ] better be Tuesday night
better be your night this is a huge
opportunity for these kids
in the contender series post-fight
presser white fielded some questions
about UFC 280 in video obtained from the
official UFC YouTube channel white gave
behind the scenes details on how the
Shawn O'Malley peor yon fight came
together
you know we're in matchmaking and and
Sean Shelby actually came up with that
fight Sean Shelby wanted that fight
I said are you out of your mind that
that you don't make that fight now this
mad he told me why you make it uh and
O'Malley's ready you know O'Malley's
about to be 28 years old in October in
his absolute prime right now hits like a
truck
you know
he ended up he ended up selling me on it
and uh and more importantly both guys
wanted it and even more important than
that when we announced that everybody
went crazy and loves it and uh even more
important than that it should be [ __ ]
a really good fight so Hamza chamayev's
coach Andreas Michael appeared on
submission radio where he spoke about
the UFC 279 bout between chimayev and
Nate Diaz Michael was quick to Discount
the popular narrative that Hamza is
going to roll through Diaz
it's [ __ ] pure [ __ ] like Nate
has fought everyone and given Leon
Edwards a run for his money like all
right Leon Edwards was winning every
round but he gave Leon Edwards a tough
fight he's no means an easy opponent for
us and Nate Diaz is probably gonna make
money Michael then spoke about what he
would like to see next for chimayev if
he were to get past Nate Diaz
I cannot talk about what hamzat would
like but I would like to fight the
winner of Leon Usman that would be a
very tough fight for both guys the
winner of that one and then move up
directly and if adasania is still a
champion after he fights Pereira which
is a monster that guy then we would
fight the champ there whoever is the
champ there I believe in a perfect world
for us that's how it would look but you
know fighting is unpredictable thick boy
fight news caught up with UFC
bantamweight Jack short to hear his
thoughts on the UFC London card
incredible night for the scousers at UFC
London 2. when you think her last one
can't be topped meatball Molly lets
lightning strike twice with another
crazy spinning elbow KO Paddy showed he
can deal with adversity in and out of
the cage after a tough first round he
comes in strong in the second and gets a
slick submission win against a solid
opponent and also he goes on to win over
even more fans with some touching and
true words in the post-fight interview
about men's mental health not a lot to
say about Tom other than I was gutted to
see it and like that wishing him a
speedy recovery he will be back better
than ever looking for more original MMA
content check out the rest of thick boy
YouTube exclusive interviews opinion and
fight analysis is available weekly on
the shop show food truck Diaries and
Fight Night flashbacks subscribe so you
don't miss any of the action